children who experience physical
cognitive or emotional neglect say
because their mother was sick and their
father was busy often face anxiety as a
result their body produces stress
hormones if this happens a lot these
hormones become toxic for their
developing brain which then later can
repress emotional and cognitive
well-being for life
the real story of daniel rukarianu who
spent part of his early childhood in a
romanian orphanage shows the full impact
neglect can have
the story began in 1966 when romania's
then leader nikolai ceausescu wanted to
make his country a world powerhouse and
came up with laws to increase the
country's population abortion and
contraception were declared mostly
illegal while the law led to a rapid
rise in birth rates many of the poorer
families were unable to take care of all
their children and daniel and around
half a million others were sent to
state-run institutions
[Music]
in most orphanages there were no toys no
books or anything else to stimulate
cognitive development many kids just
stared at the bare ceilings waiting for
their next meal
due to the lack of human contact some
babies develop strategies for
self-stimulation such as rocking back
and forth
the cognitive neglect often led to lower
iq scores delayed language development
and a lack of creative thinking this
happens because our brains build
connections with every new experience
and stimulation if there are no rich
experiences during the first years of
life the period in which the brain
develops the fastest children cannot
build the foundations necessary for
optimal future learning they miss out
for life
daniel lived with over 400 other
children and their shared bedrooms were
hardly ever cleaned the meals were
mostly tiny portions of boiled cabbage
which the staff would sometimes steal to
eat themselves
some supervisors used violence to
control the orphans others encouraged
the older kids to beat daniel to
humiliate him and exercise authority
the consequences of physical neglect and
lack of basic nutrients caused most
orphans to suffer from stunted growth
some children contracted hiv and
hepatitis b as a result of the reusing
of medical supplies the physical abuse
caused severe bruising and other
injuries the overworked and
under-trained staff hardly ever soothed
the crying children in fact they barely
spent any time with daniel at all some
children were left completely alone with
their worries others hid their feelings
from the very people who ought to
protect them since they feared being
hurt
[Music]
emotional neglect and anxiety lead to an
excessive production of the stress
hormones known as adrenaline and
cortisol which is like poison for the
developing brain but the experience also
distorted the children's understanding
of love and human relationships they
learned to trust nobody and as adults
often suffered from depression insomnia
and social anxiety
when ciaosku's regime was eventually
overthrown and the conditions inside the
orphanage were shown on television
researchers from around the world came
to examine the nameless children mri
scans later showed that some had smaller
volumes of brain mass the resulting
research made a strong case that not
only is nutrition vital to a child's
development but so is human contact to
help the children a large number were
adopted into foreign families
but even after being adopted many had
problems forming loving bonds to their
new parents
this aligns with the attachment theory
and the notion that a child needs to
establish a loving relationship with at
least one primary caregiver early in
life
daniel was quite lucky with his family
while he continued to experience trauma
and anxiety he went on to have a
university education started a family of
his own and later he founded a
non-profit organization for neglected
children
if you grew up in a loving environment
count yourself really really lucky if
you experienced forms of neglect try to
internalize the idea that it was never
your fault and maybe not even your
parents fault either
to read what we think can be done if you
have ever experienced neglect read the
descriptions below
one way is to share your thoughts about
neglect and how you think it affects you
today
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education
visit our patreon that's patreon.com
sprouts